de débuter ses titres direction tout de
suite la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris où le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 se poursuit une nouvelle
audience aujourd'hui avec une énième
sortie polémique du principal accusé on
retrouve sur place que tient pique nique
qui suit ce long feuilleton judiciaire
quel siècle quels ont été les premières
déclarations tout à l'heure de salles
abdeslam
bien salades des cinqs était forcé de
défendre le djihad d'où ses propos
polémiques mais il fait plutôt profil
bas il est en chemise blanche il est
très calme et très volubile dans la
déclaration préliminaire il a déclaré
qu'il n'avait ni tué ni blessé personne
et d'ailleurs il continue à le dire
qu'il ne le fera pas et qu'il n'est pas
un danger pour la société orange en
préambule il a déclaré qu'il prédisait
des peines sévères pour des personnes
des gens des accusés qui n'ont tué
personne je voudrais dit il que l'accord
envoie un autre message car si un
terroriste qui s'apprête à commettre un
attentat il ya des explosifs fait
machine arrière égard il n'aura pas
envie de le faire puisqu'elle sait qu'il
sera puni s'il se ravise et donc il fait
évidemment on suppose référence à son
propre cas du prix même avait jeté sa
ceinture explosive avant de passer à
l'acte donc on dirait que c'est sa ligne
de défense
et quelle a été la suite de son discours
seule fois sur une ligne enfin en tout
cas en début d'audience c'est à dire une
confusion entre les diktats de l'état
islamique qu'il s'applique à justifier
même dans toutes ces exactions et ses
propres agissements il a fait allégeance
1010 bien qu'il n'a pas de sang sur les
mains et qui n'a finalement rien fait ou
peu de choses alors il veut évidemment
qu'un ordre islamique se répandent sur
toute la terre et cueillir charia soit
imposé et selon selon lui eh bien les
combattants ont tous les droits que leur
confère leur idéologie il a expliqué
aussi que ces attentats dont on parle en
ce moment et et du djihad défensif pur
et pour éviter la réduction du
territoire de l'état islamique qui était
menacé par les bombardements de la
coalition alors le président a rétorqué
à rire tout vous vous défendez de ça en
tuant des innocents dans une salle de
concert normalement on attaque des
militaires et salades et ça m'a répondu
il travaillait militairement avec les
moyens du bord ils n'ont pas de missiles
il utilise ce qu'ils peuvent est-ce que
ça va bien cela va évoquer les
préparatifs katia
alors oui justement pour se dédouaner ne
savait rien les ordre aurait été donné
au dernier moment autant à son frère
inquiets de ses danseuses ont explosé
qu'à lui et les gens qui étaient au
dessus et je le cite ont jugé nécessaire
de faire ce projet de monter une cellule
en europe mais les gens qui sont revenus
en europe ne se connaissaient pas ils ne
savaient pas ce qu'ils allaient faire
beaucoup voient bien que salah dessin
mais c'est de dire lui minimum est
vraiment très très peu de détails sur
les complicités et les responsabilités
en revanche il insiste beaucoup sur le
fait qu'il n'a pas tué pour essayer de
minorer sa peine merci katia technique
pour toutes ces précisions ont
directement de la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris merci aussi à ma cisma
renée rose qui vous accompagnent
derrière la caméra